the ibm cloud prep web application the
ibm consulting cloud accelerator and ibm
instanta's recognition in the latest
gartner magic quadrant all on this
episode of ibm tech now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
ibm technology
now i know we're barreling headlong into
summer but that does not mean that we're
slowing down when it comes to providing
you with opportunities to learn and
that's why the ibm center for cloud
training is excited to introduce a new
web app called ibm cloud prep
cloud prep is your perfect study
companion as you prepare for one of the
many cloud certification exams offered
by the center for cloud training
cloud prep makes studying for your test
easy you can take advantage of flash
cards detailed study guides and practice
quizzes
you can even save the items you want to
review again including those pestering
quiz questions that gave you a little
bit of trouble on the first go around
best of all ibm cloud prep is free just
like the role-based training it helps
you study for
this means everyone everywhere can learn
about all things cloud through hands-on
labs and sessions with technical experts
to check out the app and learn more see
the link i've got in the description of
this video
next up let's take a look at the newly
released ibm consulting cloud
accelerator
in today's world large enterprises are
at an inflection point they're faced
with the opportunity to be new
disruptors or risk being left behind
to be the disrupter you need to
accelerate your digital transformation
while also addressing key impediments
so what if you could move complex
workloads to the cloud with speed and
consistency regardless of what cloud
platform or modernization strategy you
choose
what if most of this effort can be
automated requiring highly skilled
resources for only a fraction of the
time
have no fear the ibm consulting cloud
accelerator is here to save the day
the cloud accelerator is a revolutionary
cloud acceleration platform designed to
orchestrate a collection of expert rules
tools technical assets and industry
solutions starter kits
these are packaged as hybrid cloud
journeys to drive rapid planning and low
touch execution with predictable
outcomes
to learn more about the ibm consulting
cloud accelerator and what it can do for
your organization
hit the link below
to close things out today we're thrilled
that ibm instanta has been recognized as
a leader in the 2022 gartner magic
quadrant for application performance
monitoring and observability
ibm instanta discovers maps and monitors
all services infrastructure components
and their interdependencies
it then provides the actionable
information with the full context needed
by sre and devops teams to optimize
pipelines and applications
in their latest magic quadrant gartner
recognized ibm and stana's strengths
particularly our simplified pricing
model that is straightforward to
understand and competitively priced in
the market
they also highlighted our modern
architecture design that provides
comprehensive monitoring for
cloud-native and containerized
environments
to learn more and try out ibm instanta
hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in tech now
you